jürgen vogel war 20 als seine schwester
an leukämie erkrankte sie überwand die
krankheit dank seiner knochenmarkspende
er ist überzeugter organspender und
verfechter der widerspruchslösung ich
bin für die widerspruchslösung weil ich
fest davon überzeugt bin dass wir mehr
menschen retten als in der situation in
der wir uns jetzt befinden und es reicht
und wenn es nur einer wäre reicht es der
essener bischof franz josef overbeck
dagegen ist entschieden für die
freiwillige zustimmung zur organspende
nächstenliebe können nicht staatlich
verordnet werden
bedeutsam ist dass es dabei um den
menschen geht und zwar um den ganzen
menschen und das ist ein mensch der das
recht auf völlige freiheit hat aber auch
auf selbstbestimmung und der ist
bestimmung bedeutete in allen phasen des
lebens und bedeutet das recht in einer
solchen wesentlichen entscheidungen die
hier die integrität seines körpers
betrifft sie immer zu treffen und zwar
frei und selbstbewusst selbstbestimmt na
klar sagt jürgen vogel jeder könne doch
widerspruch einlegen wenn er kein organ
spenden wolle
das ist ja auch eine einmalige
gelegenheit für alle die die dagegen
sind zu sagen ich möchte das nicht das
ist ja auch ein großer schritt und eine
große freiheit in der demokratie so zu
sagen nein sagen zu können das ist
richtig aber die freiheit sich positiv
so etwas zu entscheiden ist größer und
von da ist das die erste die anzunehmen
ist gerade wenn es um den menschen als
ganzen geht in deutschland ging die zahl
der spender nach dem skandal 20 12
drastisch zurück damals waren
krankenakten manipuliert worden um
patienten auf den listen nach oben zu
schieben
tiefpunkt war 20 17 mit 797 spendern
im letzten jahr waren ist schon wieder
932 die knapp 3000 organe spendeten
gleichzeitig warten jedoch mehr als 9000
menschen auf eine transplantation viele
seit jahren manche vergeblich sie
sterben weil sie kein organ bekommen
jeder tag den wir das im grunde genommen
so nicht regel verliert man
viele menschen leben so also das ist
hier nicht irgendwas wo wir sagen wir
reden jetzt nicht über das
fußballspielen sondern darüber dass
menschen auf organe warten und jeden tag
sterben wir sollten als deutsche gerade
aufgrund unserer geschichte und wir als
christen das recht darauf beharren
zusagen achtet den werte person vom
anfang bis zum ende und lasst den
menschen frei in seiner selbstbestimmung
beginnt die freiheit bei der organspende
beim widerspruch oder bei der zustimmung
diese frage wird der bundestag nun
entscheiden